you're considering getting your kid
their very first cell phone or looking
for ways to control their screen time
yep cnet's editorial director dan
ackerman is here to help uh dan good
morning thank you for being here this is
a big issue in a lot of households huge
uh and it starts not with screen time
but with can you trust your child with a
very expensive piece of machinery i mean
that's true and phones are expensive and
that's why for your first phone whether
it's at 10 or 11 or even a little older
you know you can get them a used phone a
hand-me-down iphone has a se model
that's a little bit less expensive a
flip phone a flip phone may get them a
little ostracized from their friend too
but you know still a legit choice
samsung makes some really inexpensive a
series phones so there are choices that
are two to four hundred dollars not a
thousand dollars twelve hundred dollars
so if you go the smartphone route very
quickly you will see most likely your
child kind of captured by one app or
another right tik tok instagram whatever
it is and they're just they're into it
how can you control that as a parent
short of taking the phone and having
fights every night the nice thing is
there's a ton of granularity in how you
can control your kid's phone frankly
your own phone too you just go into
settings you go into screen time or you
can search for parental controls and
then if your kids account you set up as
a kid account and you're the parent then
you can say you can download these apps
not these apps you can spend this much
time on this app you can do it from this
time to this time i have to sign off on
app downloads or anything else you can
get as tight or as loose as you want to
be and it depends on what level of trust
you're building up over time and maybe
that changes you know from one month to
the next or from one year to the next i
just did it this week with my almost 13
year old and i gotta say it sounded kind
it sounds complicated it's actually
really simple and it is so empowering
it's so nice to not have to like chase
the phone itself you can literally just
sit there in your chair and hit a button
that says downtime on and his phone will
shut down you're offline you're online
yeah but i think that's important you
know when my kids were coming up i was
very resistant to a cell phone because i
just didn't want them to have the access
and then i started thinking about the
safety of it and that totally changed me
around do you think that there's a
certain age that kids should have a cell
phone that's 100 it in my parent group
people i talked to they've all kind of
said that maybe 10 or 11ish is the right
age not because they need a phone yeah
because that's the age where maybe
they're going to walk to school by
themselves or self-dismiss a couple of
days and then by using the find my phone
or the you know android version of phone
tracking you can see where they are and
if there's an emergency or problem they
can get in touch with you you can get in
touch with them so that fifth grade
sixth grade 10 or 11 seems to be where
that's starting now but mostly for the
tracking less for because i need to have
a phone yep for parents who may be a
little anxious about getting a phone or
the cost of the phone is bothering them
um tell us about gizmo that's something
i see a bunch of kids have and it's a
smart watch it's a cellular smart watch
so it has you know internet connectivity
and you can make and receive calls from
it it's about 200 it's not that
expensive um but limited you can set up
who can make a call from it who can
receive a call so only like one or two
numbers they can't just go and use it
like a regular phone and it looks like a
modern smart watch so it's not going to
look weird on them it looks almost like
an apple watch
so we have one uh one kid same age as my
older son whose family has decided it's
a flip phone or nothing
you hear about that i mean is that an
option
i mean that was my first phone yeah
there's something kind of cool about a
flip phone and a lot of people who are
super into security like them because
they're almost unhackable i don't know
how great a flip phone is going to go
over with the fen group and that's
something that's kind of important for
kids i get that but there's also a
certain charm to it yeah but but safety
you can still call them and they can
still call you i understand you're going
this is a topic that's personal to you
dan because you just went through it
with your own son number one how old is
he right he's 10 now so for his 10th
birthday when he was starting the fifth
grade i said okay you can walk home from
school one day a week so
you need the phone right there how long
was that yeah
oh my gosh well listen if you're my kid
you're probably going to have you know
exposure to a lot of technology
i see him holding the phone in that
picture and he turned to the camera how
many times did you have to say his name
before he looked up about seven that's
what i'm going to say about so how did
you finally decide you were going to let
him have it at 10. because he had been
using like a hand-me-down kind of in the
house just on wi-fi and seemed
responsible with it and then i said you
know walking home from school a couple
days a week i want to be able to keep
track of where you are let's try it out
as an experiment put a bulletproof case
on it so far it's worked out pretty well
hasn't lost it hasn't broken it that's
like surprising
my son hasn't lost it or broken it
either they're better with it they value
them
we appreciate you thank you so much